My college has said that it doesn't matter what a cancer patient eats.
How could they still be so ignorant?
Um, yeah, I would agree that that is ignorance, and I don't mean that in a negative way,
but it's just lack of knowledge.
I don't understand how anybody, at this point in history, with the amount of knowledge that
is available at your fingertips, that you can still think that your diet doesn't have anything
to do with your health.
Because certainly somebody with the more serious disease, their diet would have more
to do with your health than somebody who is, let's say, feeling great, has no symptoms,
doesn't have any weight issues, has no high blood pressure, has perfect blood work.
But I guess I could understand a doctor saying, well, don't worry about what you eat
because you're doing real well.
But when someone has a health issue to say your diet doesn't do anything, beat anything,
cause anything, I don't have an answer for this.
I don't know how someone could be that foolish.
I just don't know how you're maybe because you're so invested in a drug-based system that
you can't divest yourself enough to have a rational thought.
I don't know.
You can tell to psychologist with that question, I guess.